[Música]
es es
hoy
crees que somos
lo único que sé es que nuestra gente
sí es correcto porque no hay
necesidad en estas
nuevas elecciones
necesario
tiene que renunciar seguro que la gente lo necesita quiero
decir que he hablado  sobre uh
miedo de la gente hoy
realmente esperamos
que nuestro régimen entienda por fin
que la rueda de la gente
no podría hacerlo
sí
queremos un nuevo país libre y seguro simplemente
detenga su violencia y todo
estará bien con nuestro país
este lunes  para el primero, ¿
cuál es tu reacción?
[Música]
uh, sabíamos sobre ricochet
que ella era uh que ella se
reunirá con el Sr. Putin y
realmente no sabemos de qué van a
hablar
porque no hubo ningún anuncio y  uh,
entonces no sabemos de qué van a
hablar, pero
aún así tenemos que
decir esto, de qué este acuerdo
no puede ser real en el futuro,
bueno, no puedo decir que sea un error, no, lo
son, uh, lo
lamentamos mucho.  esto
crees que es imposible en bielorrusia
quiero creer que es imposible
porque
uh en primer lugar uh [
música] ¿qué es
esta crisis política? solo se trata
de nuestro país,
son nuestros asuntos internos,
así que espero que el señor putin sea un
vicelíder y  él ve lo que está pasando en
Bielorrusia
y no dejará que
tome decisiones tan imprudentes, ¿verdad? ¿
Tienes algún contacto? [
Música]
pronto podremos hablar un día, ¿verdad?
cómo es él
y me
apoya desde la cárcel
él cree en la gente de Bielorrusia
en la gente de Bielorrusia y cree
que
lo liberarán pronto, ¿verdad? ¿Qué pasa con
Ucrania? ¿Tienes alguna noticia de ella?
Es un período pero no.
algunas noticias de uh
de nuestro país y estoy seguro de que
ella consideró que hizo lo correcto,
sé que creo que es la posición correcta
de los países europeos y
otros países,
individuos
criminales
que dijeron órdenes criminales a las personas,
es una buena presión para  ellos, ¿verdad? ¿
Consideras a Alexander?
y
sabes que es hora de que
tengamos esta victoria y construyamos este
país juntos
[Música]